hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm
checking out the trailer for goosebumps
Jack Black Amy Ryan good cast so far
tonight I'm going to be leaving a San
Diego because I am actually introducing
a film at comic-con and then I'm doing
the QA afterwards so I'm gonna be in San
Diego all weekend but I know it's Comic
Con so it's probably be a lot of big
things to do videos about so if I'm a
little bit delayed it's because I'm over
there just letting you know but in the
meantime goosebumps let's get this on
mom are you positive there weren't any
other places looking for Vice Principals
you promised you'd give you shot I
promise and I looked into it legally I
can't live on my own until I'm 18
[Music]
yeah exactly by the way I'm Hannah hi
they were just moving in you see that
fence yesterday on your side of it he's
a big teddy bear don't take it
personally it doesn't really like anyone
Oh Hannah's in trouble
oh she's locked in this house and her
dad's a psychopath
no does she have a friend
[Music]
The Abominable Snowman of Pasadena these
are all goosebumps manuscripts why are
these books locked did you unlock a book
oh no I'm sorry
I'll put it back where it belongs
[Music]
every monster fillings I have a ton of
cavities when I was 10 I didn't brush my
teeth for a whole year when anything you
can to bury here the doors but you not
with the monsters inside
30 Callie
maybe that's pretty cool man
it's like a fun family scary film you
know is gonna be that scary obviously
but it looks like a ton of fun you know
for III watch the goosebump show growing
up and I had a [ __ ] ton of books
I forgot what kind of style of books
these are called I'm gonna sound like a
total idiot but you know when it's like
you have to make a choice you got to
make a choice on how to react to thing
it's like RPG but with a book that is
[ __ ] fun and I remembered goosebumps
was the first book that did that for me
Jack Black looked sincere he doesn't
look like he's hamming it up too much
you know I was worried about that when I
first heard Jack Black but it's cool
that they're making this a comedy that
they're not just basing it on a
goosebumps book it's like something that
is a real delight for fans because
they're bringing it all the life and a
fun comical way I hope that it's a
little scary at least because goose
bones are pretty [ __ ] scary at times
really cheesy but sometimes pretty scary
so I would like it if it was a little
scary I mean it kind of even has like a
Jumanji vibe about it like one kind of
disappointing thing to me is is that
they there's a lot of books so they
could have made a whole franchise out of
it they wanted to get a franchise out of
it they could have just taken one book
at a time and tried making those books
as best as possible in two films but I
guess I I could settle for this I am I
it looks enjoyable it's just kind of
cool to know that there's a family film
coming out around Halloween because
usually Halloween are a bunch of like
r-rated horror movies or even pg-13
scary movies so the families aren't
going so it's kind of cool to know that
like hey although we has a kids spirit
about it too it's cool to have that kind
of vibe for a family too you know I'm
just feeling a little sentimental right
now anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine because if we get more
followers we can get even
more product placement Sarah Marshall
hey Ryan right so discovered your
channel a while back I tried this a
while ago but you never gave me a
shoutout
is it my hair no your hair looks cool
it's got that pink thing going on you
know your real standout anyway I watch
your reaction videos on a daily basis
Thanks
oh and salamander Sally is adorable
she's just as adorable as Chloe grace
Moretz okay I kind of agree Oh what is
Jerry's real hair color it is actually a
dark red your beard scares me sometimes
by the way I'm sorry I will shave which
horror franchise is your favorite
between Friday the 13th Halloween
fashion and Nightmare on Elm Street oh
I'm definitely more of a Halloween fan I
take it you're going to come up with
some sex shucks on that one
somehow haha ah sex joke challenge
whenever I'm challenged to do a sex joke
I can't come up with a good sex joke I
get uncomfortable I get too crude and
it's not even funny it's just like all
he's really trying hard so hot trying
hard but Sarah you're one of the few
female subs we have thank you so much
you're awesome and let's see your
facebook profile photo as I do with
everyone and this is inappropriate you
have inappropriate photos on your
Facebook I am clicking out right now
because I don't know how old you are and
that is illegal so be safe